[Music]
my name is stephanie and i'm a senior
trainer here at the georgia aquarium i'm
working with
african penguins currently we are in the
middle of
nesting season for african penguins and
we've got some really special things to
show you today we're going to start out
by showing you some veterinary daily
checks that we are doing with our
youngest chicks
that range in age from about three days
old and then our oldest chick is about
44 days old
so why don't you guys come with me and
we'll get started
[Music]
all right now that we're back here in
the backside of the habitat we're going
to get started with some of our daily
health checks with one of our
veterinarians dr sarah
this chick is about three days old we're
looking for it to gain weight every day
but in the first week of life we really
want it to double its body weight
that's something that we can use to
measure to make sure that the parents
are feeding it enough good
so this is soliciting so this is what a
chick would do
underneath the parents to let them know
hey um i'm hungry you can feed me
anytime
i know tell them you gotta tell them to
feed you all right so that's all we
needed to do with this chick
so we're just gonna put him back with
parents and let them continue to do a
great job
so this is b4 and you can see it's much
bigger it's older than the other ones
[Music]
769 grams good job
he's doing a great job gaining weight
underneath
his foster parents out there getting
bigger by the day
all right now we're gonna go check on
our older chicks
so once they reach about 21 days
they get a little bit more curious and a
little bit more exploratory of their
habitat out there
so we bring them back here to start
their training process
this is all really excellent behavior
that we're seeing the fact that i've
come
into the space and they're coming up to
me seeking attention
they are showing that we are a
positive thing in their environment
which is awesome that's exactly what
we're looking for
we typically aim for about 30 of their
body weight in their for their diet for
each day
so we do three or four feeds a day and
we
you know kind of split it up and make
sure they're getting that
good nutrition since we don't know
if they're males or females we also
don't know anything really about them
yet we haven't named them yet
so they're going by their numbers so
this nesting season we've actually had
eight penguin chicks hatch so the other
three are still out on the habitat with
their parents
they're a little bit too young to be
back here but these five
have all graduated to this stage in
their training process
and they'll start learning different
behaviors maybe
how to walk into a tunnel how to walk
onto a scale
allowing us to pick them up and look at
their feet different things like that
that can help us take better care of
them
it's great starting early because
they're super motivated they really want
to eat a lot of food
and so we can really capitalize on that
and get that training going as soon as
possible
around november each year at the georgia
aquarium
we start to put out messy material we
happen to use a dried lavender
the penguins seem to find it really
reinforcing they go and collect big
mouthfuls of it and take it back to
their nests their huts and make nice
nests with it
and if they were happen to ingest it
they can
regurgitate it pretty easily once they
make those nuts
if they lay eggs and they are viable
which means they're developing
into a chick once that chick starts to
hatch
we will monitor the progress of the
chick underneath the parents
you might have heard me say foster
parents from time to time throughout
this video and that's just because
sometimes
they lay two eggs that are viable and
it's a lot easier
to raise one chick than two we've
definitely utilized foster parents this
year we've utilized them in the past
and they do just as great a job as if it
was the
biological mom and dad throughout that
incubation process we're checking the
egg to make sure it's developing
properly
about day 35 we start looking
to see if the egg has pipped which means
the beak of the chick has started to
break through the shell
so in our natural environment african
penguins don't have a family unit
so once the chicks are old enough to
leave the nest
mom and dad don't have anything to do
with them anymore they
form their own little groups and
they won't have that bond with mom and
dad anymore once they aren't feeding
them
any longer it's really cool the way it
works once parents are done raising
their chicks in the natural environment
they turn right into molting season
and so to molt you need to eat a bunch
of fish
to get rid of all those old feathers to
get the new ones to grow in it's really
important that
a zoos and aquariums that house african
penguins that are participating in that
ssp program or the species survival plan
continue to have chicks because their
numbers are
so bad in their natural environment that
they are an endangered species now if
their numbers ever continue to get even
worse
it's possible that somebody might make a
plan
to potentially re-release animals back
out into their natural environment
now none of these chicks that you see
here would probably ever be candidates
for that
because they're so used to people now i
mean they're
they find us reinforcing but that's not
to say that down the road maybe they
couldn't have chicks that were released
just to help repopulate in south africa
and namibia
now there's nothing set yet for that
kind of plan
but it's something that we can think
about and prepare for the future if it
ever does get that bad
and so that's why keeping the genetics
as clean as possible is so important
thanks everybody for watching and
learning more about our african pigment
chicks here at the georgia aquarium
and thanks so much to buzzfeed for
hosting us
[Music]
you